in the time when the
the russians start to bumping killing
our are people killing children
killing civilian
you can
find the answer for that you just have
to
like
most of the ukrainian people stay
together start to fight
fight for for our future for our freedom
[Music]
where were you born andre
i'm born in ukraine this is a small town
uh
about like 80 kilometers from cave
what's it called
my family moved
to tokyo when i was two years old my my
dad been military in
russian
army ussr army
and
he is my sister example she is born in
podsdam in east of germany that time
there was you know life of
military
people
just travel around
the countries and
you know work for the for the army that
my family been been doing for a long
time that but
finally my dad find the place and
stuck in kiev and
that was a great life for me good very
good memory can you remember where you
were when you found out that the
invasion was happening
i was here in london
and my mom called me and
yeah she started crying and
she said that
the worry started
and
i couldn't believe in that that was
i'm still not believing you know even
almost two months
we've been in war
against russia and
i still i still can't believe this
happened
how did you feel when you got that call
devastation
is absolutely devastation
so
and then
that was very similar feeling for next
like i've said 10 days you always try to
find
the answer why it's happened
but
in the time when the
the russians start to bumping
bomb
sending bombs to
to
our cities killing our our people
killing children
killing civilians
you know you you can
you can
find the answer for that you just have
to
like
most of the ukrainian people
s is is stay together they start to
fight
fight for for our future for our freedom
was your mom calling you from ukraine
yeah she she was there in that time
and my sister is still a lot of
siblings
still in kiev still in different parts
of ukraine
i feel for
for
especially for my family but for
everyone because
you know you
actually that
that
invasion of russia that
big and massive and first
like i said i never expected that and
then i was
thinking about what can happen because
we try to have independence for 30 years
we
finally start to
you know they build our future and then
countries start to
coming up uh
very nicely
and
that was it could be
you know good start for us to
to be part of european union to
finally to get the dreams to be
independent
country
how are your family now are they safe
yeah my family is right now i mean
who's who's who's who's in kiev
you're not 100
safe because
you never know
when
the missile can
hit you
home will hit you
car or hit you
road towards you walking
but
this situation would i think
right now we
were facing and
most of ukrainian people have to live
with this
what's been the hardest moment for you
in the past two months
just
thinking about war
thinking about what's going on thinking
about
friends
population ukrainian population all the
people who lost the houses all the
people who have to leave the
leave the country
and
common refugees most of them
is
family's mother and children
because men's have to stay in ukraine
and fight
did you ever think about going over the
fight
yeah i was thinking many times but
that was not is probably not the best
solution the best solution is
using my
connection start to talking about work
helping with humanitarian aid
you know helping with refugees create
the programs talking to
charities
this is what i've been doing last two
months
ten years ago ukraine was hosting euro
2012. you played in that tournament can
you believe how much
has happened to your country in that
time
yeah
that
that also you know ten years have been a
long time
and then from 2012 to now
the country country is very improved
and like i said you know the we start to
believe it we can build our independence
from
from russian
and
we decide to move
it to be part of european union
and then there's a lot of things been
done even
2014 the war is started you know we will
have to call
um
how
house is going on that
conflict everybody was saying the
conflict that was not even conflict i
was real war but it started
2014 and then now it just
extended in much bigger
much bigger war
and
yeah
does it upset you that
ukraine's promising future has sort of
been
paused by this
yeah of course upset me a lot
we have
big potential and people is very nice
the country
the people hard workers and never
complained it
you know we know we we start to be a lot
more united
before the war i saw
something been changing in the last two
years new generation coming
people start to travel a lot more
and
inside of the country is a lot more
intelligent
young generations start to coming up
we start to be more
united integrated to
the world and that was
in my view was a lot of good things been
been been happening especially in the
last 10 years
obviously you've seen
the kind of support that's been offered
by the whole football
community how has this support made you
feel
i think uh
especially you know in a in a in here in
england been
incredible support especially from
government
and
from
from
my association football association i
spoke to
yarmolenko i spoke to zinchenko all the
the manager and teammates
fans supporting
uh ukrainian players he's supporting
also the
and all this situation what was going on
in ukraine
is everybody was looking to give the
hands
sending
all the humanitarian aid and helping
with the refugees try to get the
families here also
it's very very important sign you know
the
the football
community united together and send the
big message to to the vault we will
against the war we want this top a war
stop in ukraine
you managed dinchenko and michael
encoding you in for the ukrainian
national team are you proud of how
they've
dealt with this all i know how been
difficult for the boys yeah you know and
i've been
i tried to support i tried to call him
and encourage him to
you know not give up to to to thinking
about
the game just try to
go in the stadium and play for your
country
you know play for your fans who is
supporting you
uh which club you're playing but also
you know because
in that point the boys are representing
ukraine and then we need
um
that visibility
uh in the world you know that ukrainian
athletes can do very well
how do you feel about president zawinski
right now and how he's led the country
i'm so proud about him i'm proud
and probably some
most difficult situation he
stand up
he united the people
he's
showed the
massive
courage to every leader in the world he
didn't leave the country he stayed there
and then that was probably
you know been great uh
signal to everybody you know ukraine
gonna stand up and fight against
injustice
and i think
he'd been great leader for us
you've talked about how you're doing
some work for refugees can you tell us a
little bit about the work you've been
doing we create um some program
i've been working in the two project one
project been
you've been here in in london we work
with ukrainian ambassador
and then try to you know get
most most possible uh
ukrainian people here
is also
a lot of teams been offering
some homes and then places in academy
and then
we slowly moving the
the young
ukrainian football players to to come
here in london and spend time in academy
and play
and then second project i've been doing
in
milan
with the
mayor of milan giuseppe
and also
that was a very important project to
to help
especially for young
kids to finish the school and then
to find this the the place to
also to play some sport
what can the people who are watching
this video right now what can they do to
help
soccer aid is a great opportunity for
you to play your part for ukraine
don't be indifferent
you can
donate or you can buy the tickets or
watching tv
this all can help
ukrainian people to survive
and ukrainian refuges
to have better life
[Music]
i know
i know
and i know i know